hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe i'm your host sean
carroll
this is ariel she's making a very brief
appearance she's
not uh a camera hog she does not like to
be on the camera too much
but she also likes attention so she
wanted to be here a little bit
today we're talking about uh the q a
video for idea number 18 which was
atoms this is another one where i didn't
have any big hidden agenda that i wanted
to use the q a video to fill in for but
we did get a lot of good questions
so let's dive right into those uh one
question here
is how do quarks
like the up quark and the down quark fit
inside protons
now you might think not a problem there
are three tiny little quirks
why should it be difficult but remember
that the compton wavelength
of a particle
lambda is one over the mass
in units where h bar equals c equals one
natural units right so the heavier the
particle the smaller the compton
wavelength
now the mass of the up quark is around
2 million electron volts the mass of the
down quark is around
4 million electron volts and the mass of
the proton
is around 938
mev million electron volts that makes
perfect sense when you
say the words uh the quarks are inside
the proton it would be weird
if the quarks were heavier than the
proton right uh and then they're held
together by some other energy and that
other energy from quantum chromodynamics
goes into making up most of the mass but
what about when you think about
the wavelengths right the proton
has a smaller compton wavelength than
the quarks do
right so how is that possible well
remember the compton wavelength is not
precisely the size of
the particle or even approximately so
that's not what the constant wavelength
is quite about
we do sometimes use it that way
informally
ariel's complaining in the background we
use it sometimes that way informally
but it's it's best a rough guide the
point is that you know
it depends on the physical situation
that the particle is in how to relate
the compton wavelength to its actual
extent of the wave function which is
what really matters
so in a hydrogen atom for example the
wave function of the electron is spread
over the bohr radius
which is related to the compton
wavelength but is bigger than it
it's bigger than it by one over the fine
structure constant and that's a
reflection of the fact that
the electromagnetic force that is
binding the electron
to the proton in the hydrogen atom
allows the electron to spread out a
little bit it's a fairly
weak force because alpha the fine
structure constant is a small number
1 over 137 so the actual
radius of the wave function of the
electron is bigger than this constant
wavelength would it be
in the proton that's a very different
situation a proton is two up quarks and
a down quarks that's something we
usually say
but the reality is the proton is a
complicated mess
of quarks and gluons so the fact that
if it's true that the up quarks and down
quarks
in the proton or the neutron for that
matter are squeezed into a size
smaller than their compton wavelength
but it's not that it's impossible to
squeeze a particle
into a radius smaller than its compton
wavelength it's that the content
wavelength is the smallest radius
at which you can still think of it as
just a single particle
if the wavelength of the particle
becomes smaller than its compton
wavelength then the
energy in that particle becomes great
enough to make new particles
so it's no longer a good approximation
to think of it as just a single particle
remember the whole
journey we took from quantum field
theory to particles
has situations where you start sort of
in the vacuum and you perturb it a
little bit and you find out that it kind
of behaves like one or two or three
particles
so when you take that particle and
squeeze it to a small enough
size that's smaller than its compton
wavelength the fieldiness
kicks in and you can think of it in some
way as
the there are contributions from virtual
particles from particle anti-particle
pairs popping in and out of existence
and so if you're trying to squeeze the
up and down quarks into a region
smaller than the proton by the way
there's gluons in there too and their
masses are zeros you
could ask this question about them too
but what this means is that you should
expect that the two
up quarks and the down quark and the
proton are not sort of flying around in
empty space or they're not even all by
themselves
inside there you should expect the
proton to be some complicated
combination
of many quarks anti-quarks uh and gluons
and anti-gluons
with a total net number of three extra
quarks
in fact these are sometimes called the
valence quarks of the proton because
in fact the proton has a lot more going
on than just those it's just those three
quarks
so that's basically why it's okay to
squeeze the
quarks into a region smaller than their
compton wavelength because they're not
just single particles all by themselves
anymore and that's what the compton
wavelength is all about
this cat is not going to let us get
through this video
all right next question was again i
always uh
translate the questions a little bit
sorry about that but
why isn't there
neutronium neutronium
uh might be the name i've never heard
the word neutronium before i made it up
but
it's basically the combination of two
neutrons
neutron neutrons so this is down up down
up down down you know why can't we just
get two neutrons together into a stable
kind of nucleus
because we said that a neutron by itself
heavier than the proton it will
eventually decay
but when you put it together with a
proton then there's a binding energy
there that is negative
and so it turns out that the mass of the
deuteron one proton and one neutron is
less than the mass of the proton neutron
by themselves
so there's nowhere for the or even two
protons by themselves
so there's nowhere for the deuteron to
decay into but if you had
neutronium there's an obvious place for
it to decay into
namely a deuteron right a proton
with two ups and a down and a neutron
with one up and two downs
okay the strong interaction
is basically the same for these two
things two neutrons put together
two one neutron and one proton put
together the electromagnetic interaction
is more or less zero
in both cases because the proton isn't
pushing against other protons if there's
just one other neutron there
so all the difference between these two
things is that
here you have two neutrons and the
neutrons are heavier than the protons
so the deuteron is definitely going to
be lighter than
neutronium if there were such a thing
and therefore the neutron would quickly
decay
so that's i do this i did this in some
detail because
it's a good example of the way they were
supposed to be thinking about these
things right
you say well why doesn't this exist some
conglomeration of particles
well what can it decay into are there
interactions that allow it to decay
are there conservation laws that allow
it to decay and so forth
in this case if there were neutronium it
would be massive enough that it could
just decay into
deuteron right away pretty quickly or
maybe even just decay into you know two
free protons or something like that
okay now here's a more subtle one um
what breaks the symmetry again my
rephrasing of the question
of a single atom
uh with an electron
in a p orbital
i forget whether i actually use that
nomenclature but if you took your
chemistry class
uh in high school or college you've
heard the phrase p orbital the p
orbitals are the orbitals
that the electron can be in that sort of
have this double lobe structure
oops i can do better than that
gotta go with strength you can't just
hesitate um so the p orbital is the one
where the electron is not in its
spherically symmetric lowest energy
state it's in the next
highest energy state and there are three
of them because
it could be oriented along the z-axis
the x-axis or the y-axis right three
perpendicular axes
so there's it's inhomogeneous it's not
spherically symmetric and there are
three of them
times two because there are two spin
states for the two electrons there's six
total ways for the electrons to be in
this p
orbital and so the question is you just
had one atom with one
such electron right uh and it was out
there in the world
in empty space let's say um
who picks which one it is if it just has
one electron if it's in the z direction
or the x direction of the y direction
you know how do you know which one it's
going to be in
so there's actually two answers this is
a very good question there's two answers
to it
um one is you know there's nothing to
stop it from breaking the symmetry it's
nothing to stop it from just saying
uh i'm in the state of the p orbital
moved in is aligned in the x direction
right i mean that's just
how it is uh there's plenty of things
like like if you had a hydrogen
uh molecule right if you had two
hydrogen atoms that's a little dumbbell
shape thing so it
it has a preferred axis and you could
easily imagine a hydrogen molecule
sitting out there in empty space
violating the symmetry it would be a
random sense in which it violated the
symmetry but
it could happen there's nothing that
stops that but the other thing is which
is a little more subtle which is again
why i thought it'd be an interesting
thing to talk about
these there are three states six really
if you count the spins
um for the p orbitals and they all have
exactly the same energy
right there's no difference between the
energy of the orbital point this way
versus this way versus this way
and in uh so what we call that is a
degeneracy
you say that these energy states are
degenerate
they have exactly the same energies so
if you the r and the reason why that's
interesting is if you have two states
that are slightly different in energy
then like we just talked about
the heavier one the one with more energy
will like to decay
into the lighter one and that's a
natural thing to have happen and you can
calculate the rate at which
that's going to happen et cetera but if
they're degenerate then one's not going
to decay
into the other but the point is you
could create a state
that is any combination of these three
and it would still have the same energy
by combination i really mean literally a
quantum superposition
okay so we picked out
these three states as a basis for what
that electron
could be doing the electron is exactly
like the spin of a single electron could
be spin up or spin down
right that's what we say sometimes what
we mean is
those are the two basis states but the
electron can have its spin in any
direction right you can have a
combination of any of those
and the energy would be the same as long
if the energy if the electron were in a
magnetic field
then its spin would be lower energy one
way and higher energy some other way but
if there's no magnetic field the
electrons just out there in empty space
all the different spin directions it
could point in are created equal
likewise here this is not a spin this is
a
spatial configuration of the spatial
wave function of the electron
so when we say it could be pointed z
direction x direction y direction what
we really mean is those are the three
basis states and the true wave function
could be linear combination a
superposition of
any of those and would still have the
same energy so you could imagine taking
all sorts of combinations you don't need
to be fixed
to those particular configurations
physics students of course are tortured
by this stuff
because when you do perturbation theory
in atomic and nuclear physics
the rules are slightly more complicated
when you have degenerate energy states
uh but for us we're just going to say
they're there and and you could be in
them or combinations of them that's all
we're gonna need to say
okay uh here's a more conceptual
question um
i'm not even sure quite sure how to say
this um how
can
two fermions let's say it this way how
can two fermions
not have the same wave function
so we said when we're talking about what
a fermion is
that the whole point of the fermion was
that a fermion two identical fermions
cannot be in the same quantum state
right and a quantum state is just a
synonym for the wave function in the
unless you're a bohmian or hidden
variables person quantum state means the
wave function
so the whole point of a fermionic field
is that the excitations in that field
the particle-like excitations in that
field
are not allowed to be in the same
wave function so when you have some big
wave function for two particles x1 and
x2
it typically for a fermion looks like
psi 1 of x1
side 2 of x2 where psi 1 and x2 are
different
then minus psi 1 of x2
side 2 of x1 so this guarantees that if
you switch x1 and x2 you get minus what
you started with that's what makes it a
fermion
and so the question here i think if i'm
interpreting it correctly
is due to as usual a sloppiness of the
way
that we talk about these things and the
sloppiness of the way that we talk about
these things comes down to
the same wave function language so
for people who care about the
foundations of quantum mechanics and
what quantum mechanics is really saying
um it's an important fact that different
parts of the universe different
particles or different subsets or
whatever
do not in principle have separate wave
functions they're all part of
the wave function of the universe by
which in this toy example we would mean
this capital psi that's the wave
function
and then we talk about but but in
particular special circumstances we can
talk about the individual wave function
for a single
particle okay so here you would be very
naturally saying
let's say you had an electron that was
in one atom and another electron that
was in totally another atom
okay the total wave function for those
two electrons has to take this kind of
form
where there's some anti-symmetrization
between them because they're fermions
and they're identical particles okay
but psi one and psi two in that case are
completely different things
psi one is in this atom cy2 is in that
atom the point of this kind of
construction is to say
you can't say which electron is in which
atom
but you can say there's an electron in
this atom and there's electron in the
other atom does that make sense
there's no label distinguishing the two
electrons so
it's not like some pre-existing this
electron is named alice and this
electron is named bob and alice is in
the hydrogen atom and bob is in the
helium atom or something like that
that doesn't make sense electrons don't
have names okay
but you can say there is a part of the
electron
two electron state that is in the helium
atom and another part that's in the
hydrogen atom okay
so very very often we are therefore
sloppy about it we talk about the wave
function of the electron in the hydrogen
atom and the wave function
of the other one so we talk about the
wave function psi one
and the wave function psi two okay and
psi one and psi two cannot be exactly
the same wave function because then this
whole thing would just be zero and
that's not a very interesting
quantum state so it's a sloppiness of
language
problem it's still true for these
identical particles
for the quantum fields that give rise to
them that if you're careful
and you're doing your quantum mechanics
and talking about it correctly you would
say that
everything is part of the single
universal wave function of the universe
but in special circumstances where the
wave functions of the individual
particles
can sensibly be talked about
individually
we do that and in the back of our minds
we have all the footnotes and the
caveats and saying but of course it's
anti-symmetrized and all that stuff
so there's nothing there's it's
meaningful to say
two electrons cannot have the same
quantum state
and yet those electrons are described by
the same quantum state because we mean
different things by the word quantum
state in those two sentences
in one we mean the individual wave
functions for the two
parts of this big wave function and the
other we mean the big wave function that
means everything
but this this is good this is why we're
doing the q a because you know getting
exactly right on these details
is is hard to do because once you've
been doing it once you've been playing
with it
you know what you mean when you say
these things physicists know what they
mean
when they talk about these things
therefore they can get sloppy that's
just a
you know occupational hazard i guess
okay
um here's a big one flavor violation
not really a question except what about
uh
favorable violation via neutrino
oscillations
let me explain what this means
so we said that the leptons
come in three families right
we have the heaviest one is the tau and
the town
then you have the muon and the muon
neutrino
and the electron and the electron
neutrino
when i say the heaviest one that's
clearly true for the mu on the tau and
the electron
we actually it's harder to arrange the
neutrinos we don't know how to do that
in fact these neutrinos as i've written
them don't have definite masses remember
that's
that's we didn't go into this we're not
going to go into this but neutrino
physics is complicated
there are three mass states for the
elect for the neutrinos there's
neutrino number one neutrino number two
neutrino number three
but the three mass states states of
definite mass
are combinations mixtures of what we
call the electron neutrino the tau
neutrino and the muon neutrino
these these are what we call flavor
states
and we know that because that's what are
created in interactions so for example
when you have a muon
okay so muon traveling along has muon
number
and the muon number is going to be
conserved in the weak interactions
so we mean by that is the muon can emit
a w minus
turn in muon is minus of course so it
turns into a
neutrino and that neutrino had better be
a muon neutrino oops not a
neutrino nutrient it's not going to be
an electron neutrino or a town neutrino
in fact
this is what it means to be a muon
neutrino it
means that it was the thing that was
created by a muon decaying or or he can
go backwards it can
actually turn into a muon in the right
circumstances
and then this w minus could decay into
whatever it wants it could decay
well it's going to decay into a charged
lepton or a charged
it could decay into a up quark and a
down quark for example
but it could also decay into let's say a
tau and then an anti-town neutrino
and so when you look at these diagrams
um
not only is lepton number the total
number of leptons being conserved
but there are individual conservation
laws for the three
families okay for the sometimes called
families or generations
i know that doesn't that's not
consistent nomenclature but that's what
they're called okay
so we talk about flavor
which is another it's also called
flavors or family number or generations
actually is flavor violation the right
logo for this i i think it is but you
know honestly this is not my bag i do
not i do not get into this nitty-gritty
of particle physics in my everyday
life so uh don't you know go to
wikipedia to check up on the
nomenclature here
but the point is that the electron-ness
the muon-ness the taunis whatever you
want to call them are conserved in the
weak interactions
and so there's it's an approximate
symmetry but it's not a gauge in
variance notice there's remember we
talked about the difference between a
global symmetry
and a gauge symmetry when we talked
about gauge theories gauge symmetries
are ones where you can rotate
systems individually at every point in
space and then there's a connection
field it has to relate them and that
gives rise to a force of nature
this is a global symmetry that that
keeps all of these
uh lepton numbers individually conserved
but global symmetries can be broken you
know they can be broken explicitly or
they can only be approximately true
gauge symmetries are either there or
they're not you know you have a
connection and you have a force or you
don't
but global symmetries can be approximate
so it turns out that these symmetries
that keep taunis muon-ness and
electron-ness conserved
are only approximate so under under the
right circumstances
you can have a situation where a muon
neutrino let's say
just oscillates into an electron
neutrino
uh this is the subject of neutrino
oscillations and the reason why is
because
neither the muon nor the electron are
have a definite mass
right so they can actually change
identities into each other without
violation violating conservation of
energy or anything like that
the rate at which it happens depends on
the environment they move in and the
whole bit but this
these processes are crucial for things
like the solar neutrino problem right
we for a long time we had these pretty
good
models what was going on in the middle
of the sun not perfect
and there were there were complicated
complications that people worried about
but people like john bacall and others
worked out what was going on inside the
sun
and of course when you get you know a
neutron and a proton together
and they fuse together to make deuterons
um actually
let's not say that when you have two
protons and you fuse them together
there's no stable bound state of two
protons but there's one of a proton and
neutron
the deuteron so you have to turn one of
those protons into a neutron and that's
the weak interactions that work and you
emit
a neutrino even a bunch of neutrinos so
neutrinos should come out of the sun if
nuclear fusion is going on there and
then when we
built uh experiments to look for them
ray davis and other people
they did not find as many neutrinos as
they should
the reason why there's a long story
about the reason why
msw effect and all that stuff but the
short answer is
neutrinos of one flavor can turn into
neutrinos of another flavor
and so the sun was producing electron
neutrinos and we were trying to detect
electron neutrinos but they had turned
into something else
along the way and you might say but
how can that be allowed if you have this
this symmetry or this conservation of
electron this mu oneness and tauntus and
the answer is you don't
the answer is the weak interactions this
is a weak interaction
anything that is mediated by a w boson
or a z
boson is a weak interaction and
in particle physics some interactions
can
conserve certain quantities while others
do not conserve
those quantities so the weak
interactions conserve
electronics muon-ness and townis
separately but neutrino oscillations do
not
they violate them but neutrino
oscillations are sort of more rare and
hard to observe so
if you didn't look very hard if you
didn't do these nobel prize-winning
experiments that
davis and others did you'd be hard to
tell that
uh these different numbers of
electronics muon this and talnus were
being violated in these interactions
so it's just another situation where
there's an approximate symmetry which is
pretty good
notice that for quarks it's the same
story but much worse
quarks can actually just violate uh
these symmetries even in the weak
interactions
so you know that there's like the up
down up quark and down quark or a family
and then charm and stranger a family and
then top and bottom are a family
but there's there are ways to mix these
things together
much more easily than you can with the
leptons something called the
uh kabibo kobayasha maskawa matrix the
ckm mixing matrix explains all that
again
you can see why we're not going to get
into this there's a there's a neutrino
mixing matrix there's a quark mixing
matrix and
infinite fun to play with the standard
model of particle physics and it's it's
near
neighbors but we don't have time or or
energy to do that a very good job the
short answer is
these numbers are not completely
conserved and the neutrino oscillations
are how they're violated
okay i may even have mentioned that in
the original
lecture but certainly not very clearly
okay here's another question
can there be
more than three generations
so here we have three generations of
leptons there's a matching three
generations of quarks
once you've found three it's pretty easy
to say well okay
how do you know that there are not more
i mean even finding the three was
interesting right you know we
uh when probably i've
told the story already but anti-matter
was discovered by carl anderson at
caltech in the 1930s i think 35
it had been predicted by paul dirac once
he invented the dirac equation you can
figure out that if you believe the dirac
equation and take it seriously
if you have a negatively charged
particle with a certain mass
there should be a positively charged
particle with the same mass and the same
properties
and so we knew about the electron direct
basically was predicting the positron
but because it was all newfangled and
not settled yet people weren't
completely sure
whether or not we should take that
seriously like maybe there was some
symmetry breaking
and what iraq was predicting was really
the proton which we
already knew about right so the
prediction of the positron was taken
very seriously by some people less
seriously by others
um carl anderson detected it he went on
to the roof at a building in caltech
built a cloud chamber
and then from cosmic rays you know he
didn't have a particle accelerator he
just used cosmic rays coming from the
sky
to detect a particle that looked exactly
like an electron
except it was deflected the other way in
a magnetic field so you knew it had a
positive charge
people were so skeptical some people
said like are you sure you're not
holding the picture upside down
if you think that it's being deflected
the wrong way they checked they were not
holding the picture upside down
so then he very quickly anderson very
quickly also
discovered the muon so he discovered and
the anti-muon which is another thing so
these cosmic rays
hit the atmosphere
cosmic rays a little digression here
what's going on uh you have the earth
here we are you have the atmosphere of
the earth
right and then you have here's caltech
and here's carl anderson on the roof of
a building and he has a little bubble
chamber
cloud chamber i can never keep track
which was which and what happens is a
super high energy cosmic ray which is
probably a proton
or an antiproton sometimes they're
heavier nuclei like a
helium nucleus or something like that
super high energy comes in and hits the
atmosphere
and so most of these cosmic rays never
get to the ground where you can observe
them
but what they do is they hit an atom and
then they
create a cascade of many different
particles and some of those particles
are going to go into your detector
okay so a lot of the particles that are
produced
are muons and anti-muons so anderson as
well as
electrons and pro and positrons so
anderson was able to discover the
positron and also the muon and the
anti-muon
but at that point you know we knew about
protons and neutrons
and we knew about electrons and
neutrinos okay did we know about
neutrinos
i'm not even sure if we knew about
neutrinos to be honest i forget when
those happen but this
this era that we're talking about right
now circa 1935.
so the muon
was like literally this was the thing
that uh
that inspired uh ii robbie to say who
ordered that
it was a particle that was just like the
electron but heavier
in fact it was originally called the mu
meson because we were beginning to
discover things like pions and other
mesons which we now know the real mesons
are quark antiquark pairs but this was
another particle that you know didn't
fit in anywhere and it decayed
and so forth so they thought it was
another meson but it's not it's a lepton
and eventually we realized okay it's
part of another generation the electron
has its neutrino and mulan has this
neutrino and then we discovered the tau
that was a big deal um in the quark
sector you know we the
up and down quarks were there right away
and
the strange quark was also there right
away
um because the putting together of the
quark model by murray gilman and
yuval neymon and others relied on the
fact that there were three different
kinds of quarks up down
and strange the discovery of the charm
cart
took a lot longer was until the seven
not a lot longer but it was until the
70s that evidence
uh came in favor of that glashow and
ileopolis and mayani
had actually predicted the existence of
the charm quark and uh burkane had
something to do that also
again the details are very messy but
they predicted it because it helped
explain the small rate of certain
interactions in particle physics
and then it was eventually discovered
but then again okay so that's two
generations and then the bottom quark
was like a whole other thing there's a
whole other surprise uh
i think leon letterman uh and his
collaborators get the credit for that
and uh so all these were surprises like
the first three generations
all i'm trying to say is that there was
never
at the beginning of particle physics a
principle that there should be
generations
at all right they kept just being
surprising and discovered and being
discovered
so we've discovered three generations so
far so far therefore it is completely
natural to ask
could there be a fourth now if the
there's there's sort of a short but
cheating answer
if you thought that all neutrinos were
very very low mass
you know the three neutrinos we know
about are much lighter than anything
else right
much lighter than the electron which is
the next lightest particle
if you thought that the fourth
generation included a light neutrino
then it's ruled out there's plenty of
experiments and even cosmology
experiments the big bang nucleosynthesis
for example
that are that would be very very
different if there was a fourth
generation of light neutrino
okay uh so that's not true so there's
there's definitely not a third
generation that is
exactly like the for the three that we
know about there's no not a fourth
generation
um of course you could imagine a fourth
generation where even the neutrino was
super duper heavy
and there you know we don't know for
sure like maybe there there could be but
it'd be really weird like that neutrino
has to be really heavy
in order to evade detection and the
charged lepton has to be heavy to in
order to not evade detection
you know in the large hadron collider
we've been looking we've been looking
for new particles and you know for that
matter at fermilab
uh the tevatron at fermilab before the
lac even turned on
and at slack at stanford at other places
we've been looking for
new particles lep was a particle
accelerator at cern predating the lhc
we haven't found any of these new
particles yet so
the smart money is there are only three
generations there's no reason why just
because there are three there have to be
an infinite number
in fact there are versions of string
theory where you can explain why there
are three generations in terms of the
topology
of the compact dimensions that's one of
the cool things that got people excited
about string theory in the 1980s
depending on the topology of the compact
dimensions you could actually predict
that there should be three
i mean other topologies would predict a
different number so it's
not a very good prediction but you could
explain it let's put it that way
but we're still looking and you know
even if you don't find them directly the
limits are very very good
because you can you can look for things
indirectly in particle physics remember
we have all these
um virtual particles and so we do we do
actually look at processes with the
particles that we know
about and even if there are other
particles that we haven't detected
directly
their existence could affect the rate of
the interactions of the particles that
we have detected
and we haven't seen that either so
there's a very very good
limits on the possibility of more than
three generations
again can't say for sure but there's no
reason for them to be there
uh the neutrino would have to be really
really heavy and we've seen zero
evidence so there's not a lot of people
in particle physics thinking hard these
days about more than three generations
could be true but we haven't thought
about it yet or we haven't found any
evidence for it yet
okay keep going more questions
um how can this happen
a muon remember i just showed you this
picture of a muon
decaying into a neutrino
by a w boson which then itself decays
into let's say let's put make an
electron now why not
we'll even put the little arrows because
these guys are fermions
and an electron anti-neutrino so
the question is how can this happen
and you might say well why why not and
the answer is
uh if i do this if i erase this part
now it looks like the muon has decayed
into a w
particle and a neutrino right and
you know we that can't happen
why because the w is much heavier than
the muon
right you can't a light particle can't
decay into a heavier one
so if you thought that this diagram
which represents the decay of a mu1 to a
neutrino and a w minus
can't happen then how in the world can
this one
actually happen right how can the
something that you made out of something
that can't happen be possible
well the answer is that in this diagram
this is a virtual
w boson so remember the rules of virtual
particles are they're not really
particles they're
a nice mathematical way of talking about
the excitations in quantum fields
and they don't have to obey the rules
for
the relationship between mass and energy
so for this particle you know e squared
is m squared
plus p squared where this is the
momentum
okay this is what's supposed to be true
but for a virtual particle this is not
true
so it has an energy it has a momentum
but they don't add up to make the mass
in exactly this way
so even though the mass of
the w boson is heavier than that of the
mu in this kind of diagram that virtual
w
can have an energy that is less than the
energy
of the original muon so within this
diagram this is completely okay
it's an interesting fact numerically
quantitatively
that diagrams where all the particles
are
as close to being real as possible
remember this is called this this
expression
is called the mass shell
condition because if you plot
it like this p e
this equation looks like this
it's sort of a shell a hyperboloid up
there okay
and being on the mass shell
is when a virtual particle is almost or
very close to
that particular relationship so this
relationship
e e squared equals m squared plus p
squared is just true for real particles
uh you can come close to it but not be
on it
if you're a virtual particle for a
virtual particle this relationship may
or may not be true
but what i guess what i'm saying in a
long-winded way is the closer you are to
it
the bigger that feynman diagram is
numerically the stronger the
contribution is
if particles can decay through other
particles that are close to the mass
shell then that decay is more likely to
happen and this is why
certain kind of interactions and certain
kinds of decays and particle physics
are bigger than you might expect because
there's some resonance near
a real particle energy but here
the w particle has to have much less
energy than it wants to because of its
mass
that's yet another reason why these weak
interactions are weak because they're
hard to go through
a little bit the w has to be very very
virtual for this to happen
okay what's next uh
good for bariogenesis
remember bariogenesis is the idea that
in the early universe
maybe there were just as many
baryons as anti-baryons or almost just
as many
quarks and antiquarks okay
and they almost all annihilate away
except for
one out of a billion they do not one out
of a billion
quarks or antiquarks do not annihilate
away um
leaving us with some excess quarks and
that's why we have more matter than
antimatter in the universe
and when they annihilate away when those
quarks and antiquarks annihilate away
uh they turn into photons mostly they
turn to other things as well but
eventually they turn to photons so the
question is where do the photons go
well you could ask this question
not just about photons not not just
about baryons but about electrons the
same thing is true with electrons there
were
almost as many positrons as electrons in
the early universe
and they eventually annihilate away so
if you think about it what you would
expect this is the very early universe
we're talking about here
you have this hot dense gas full of
particles
and remember temperature
is approximately the average kinetic
energy
of particles
so and remember energy
is mc squared so if the temperature
which has units of energy is higher than
the mass of a particle
and units where c equals one then you
expect those particles and
anti-particles to be created and
destroyed
all the time right there's a whole bunch
of particles just popping
out of existence from the ordinary
interactions of other particles
and what happens is as the temperature
goes below
let me see if i can plot this again
making this up as i go along here
so as time goes on here as the universe
expands and cools
the temperature goes down
okay and so let's say that you have you
know the mass of some particle the mass
of an electron let's say
so here's the mass of the electron
there's a temperature in fact let's call
this two times the mass of the electron
because
two times the mass of electron is the
mass of an electron and a positron right
so at temperatures higher than the mass
of the electron
there are e minus e plus pairs
being created and destroyed all the time
because the average energies as two
particles colliding together is enough
to make
an electron positron pair all what i'm
saying here now for electrons and
positrons goes equally well for quarks
and antique works
and then below this there's just photons
so you imagine that all these electrons
and positrons are flying around
sometimes they're annihilating but
sometimes they're being created also
right so at temperatures higher than
their mass
there's an almost equilibrium between
particles being created and destroyed
whereas when you drop below that mass
when the temperature goes so low that
you can annihilate particles but not
create them anymore
then the particles go away they just
convert into photons you get something
like
uh there's many different ways to do
this but here's e minus
e plus the the positron uh
and here's a way to find the diagram
that turns it into two
photons for example so
where so if this story is true that in
the super early universe things were hot
and dense and there were all sorts of
particles flying around
of all sorts of different uh charges and
masses and everything
and then as you cool down there's a
series of transitions
where those particles annihilate away
into photons the question you're asking
is
shouldn't there be this gas of all sorts
of photons bouncing around in the
universe
so i'm saying it in you know
intentionally provocatively because yes
there
is it's called the cosmic microwave
background um
the number of baryons
in our observable universe the excess of
baryons over antibarions it's about 10
to the 80th
baryons in our in our universe the stars
and the gas and the dust and all that
stuff
the number of photons in our observable
universe is around 10 to the 88th
way more okay so roughly speaking
the photons went to form the cosmic
microwave background you know
they're they were roughly speaking
similar numbers
of photons and baryons before the
baryons annihilated away
and when the baryons did annihilate away
they created approximately as many
photons as there had been baryons
so you increase the number of photons by
a factor of two or something like that
but it's not a big deal in fact it's not
even as much as that because there are a
whole bunch of different
particles that annihilate away and
create photons baryons are just one of
them
so by the time the quarks were
annihilating away there had been a whole
other bunch of particles that had
already annihilated away and there were
a lot more photons than baryons
so the photons didn't go anywhere we're
observing them today in our telescopes
right in our microwave background
telescopes and our radio telescope so
they're still out there
suffusing the world around us back in
the days when people used to not have
cable tv
you could say that ten percent of the
static on your cable tv
on your on your uh broadcast tv came
from the cosmic microwave background
photons
they're just all around us uh some of
those were created by baryons
annihilating in the early universe there
you go
all right where are we good we're making
progress here okay here's a good one
two more two more questions one is um
can you have negative mass particles
can the mass of a particle be less than
zero after all
charges of particles can be positive or
negative could
um particles have masses less than zero
well you could certainly imagine that
being true i mean this is again what
theoretical physicists do for lithium
say what if this were true what would
the world be like
so you can imagine particles of masses
less than zero in fact um
i did this once i wrote a paper with uh
mark trodden and um mark hoffman on
the question so there's this idea that
um how much detail should i go into you
remember there's dark energy
right dark energy is a big deal so some
people say well there could be
a dark energy field a quintessence field
some field phi that has a potential
energy
and the field is rolling down and the
slope of the potential is slow
so gradual that this amount of energy
here is almost constant as the universe
expands so it's
dark energy quintessence
so dark energy these are two slightly
different terms
remember the vacuum energy is strictly
constant energy that can exist
in empty space dark energy is any kind
of energy that is almost
constant maybe not exactly constant but
it could be slowly varying or it could
be exactly constant okay
quintessence is the particular idea that
you could have a form of dark energy
where the form of energy the source of
energy was a scalar field slowly rolling
down its potential
okay that's the lingo you need to know
so
some people robert caldwell mark
kaminkowski and some other people said
well
we have an energy density rho remember
is the greek letter we use for energy
density
and we usually say that is kinetic
plus potential okay
and we usually say that is one half
phi dot squared the time derivative of
phi
plus v of phi so they said
um what if
we imagine again this is what we do what
if we imagined
a form of energy that they called
phantom energy
phantom which has the the feature that
the kinetic energy is negative
one-half minus one-half phi dot squared
plus v of five okay
because if that were true i drew this
picture here where the field is rolling
down its potential
but if the kinetic energy were negative
if you go into the equations of motion
what happens is the field would tend to
roll up its potential
so in this case the derivative of the
energy density
phantom over time
remember this needs to be close to zero
to be dark energy you don't want the
energy density to be changing that much
but in ordinary quintessence theory it
would gradually decay
in the phantom energy it would gradually
increase
so you get more and more energy over
time
and that is what leads to what they call
the big rip
so you're imagining it literally in
empty space i mean it was weird enough
just to imagine that an empty cubic
centimeter of space
has energy in it what these folks are
imagining is there it has energy that is
increasing over time empty space right
and in a finite amount of time it can
reach an infinite energy and that would
be a singularity and general relativity
and they called it the big grip
so what i did uh with the two marks is
to say look
let's take this seriously as a theory of
particle physics
so you can derive something like this
from a lagrangian
right and you can quantize it and get
particles and those particles have
negative masses
that's exactly what this theory says
this is different from a tachyon
a tachyon particle actually has an
imaginary mass and travels faster than
the speed of light
this is an ordinary particle in terms of
it's not being tachyonic it doesn't move
fast from the speed of light but it has
a negative mass
here is the problem with that remember
we just had a discussion up here
about energy conservation and um
particle decays so the muon can decay
into neutrino electron
anti-neutrino because the sum of masses
of these folks is lower
right and the mass of the original
muon but if you could
if you have particles these five
particles with negative energy
then what you can do is have an electron
and it can decay i'm not going to say
exactly how because we don't know how
but it could decay into a muon
so something happens we don't know
exactly what
electron decays into muon you say how
can a light particle decay into a
heavier particle
well by emitting
a particle with mass less than zero
right
so if you have particles with masses
less than zero
then light particles can now decay into
heavy ones while still maintaining
energy conservation
in fact
here's another thing that could happen
nothing
could decay into let's say an electron
a positron and a bunch of five particles
literally empty space could decay into
some positive mass particles and some
negative mass particles
that's bad in fact you calculate the
rate at which this happens and it's
almost instantaneous basically it is
instantaneous except for their you know
you normalize and put it cut off and
stuff like that
so the vacuum empty space
is oops is unstable
the reason why empty space is stable in
ordinary physics
is because every particle every
excitation
everything that you can do to the
quantum field increases energy
okay so if energy is conserved and you
start with zero energy
there's nowhere to go if all non-zero
energies are positive numbers
if you start with zero energy nothing's
going to happen
but if you can have both positive and
negative energies
you can start with zero energy and stay
in the zero energy sector in an
infinite number of different ways and so
that will happen quantum mechanically
and we don't observe that the world
remains more or less stable and you can
try to fix this and people did
so you know our paper got a lot of
citations because people are trying to
you know wiggle around
our conclusion but i think it's
basically true like unless you jump
through hoops and try really really hard
negative mass particles are bad in fact
there's a name for these particles these
are called ghosts
because there are similar particles that
are allowed but they're sort of only
virtual ghosts
if you have real particles that are
ghost-like negative masses
that's generally considered bad okay
again there's no it's very very
difficult to have
absolute impossibilities in particle
physics because people are very clever
but that's the way i would bend
all right final question um
testing quantum field theory
and new particles so
here just want to talk for a second
i said at the end of the atoms video of
the last uh
big idea video that the
if you believe in quantum field theory
if quantum field theory is more or less
correct
then we have discovered all the
particles and forces
at the microscopic level that are
relevant to our everyday lives
there's some nitpicky people who are
like what about dark matter but you know
dark matter is not part of your everyday
life
what about quantum computing well
quantum computers are made of electrons
and protons and neutrons they are
it's really true like this is this is
actually true this this claim here i'm
not going to repeat it
exactly but there's one thing that i
could have said and didn't say just for
time constraints which is well
this makes sense because what i said was
crossing symmetry right i said look if
you have some new particle here
x and you have electrons and they can
interact
then that implies that you can take an
electron and a positron
and make these x particles x particles
anti-x particles so at a particle
accelerator
if there were new particles that we
hadn't yet discovered
that were that interacted with electrons
and positrons and protons and neutrons
strongly enough to have an effect on
everyday physics we would have made them
already but there's another thing which
is well what about new
forces right so this this has no new
particles well what about new forces
and you to a large extent exactly the
same
argument works right but there's a
loophole which is what about you know
gravity okay gravity is an example of a
force
that is very weak you're never going to
see gravity at a particle accelerator
so how do you know there's not a new
force that extends over
macroscopic distances you know
centimeters or something like that
or longer than larger anything anything
that you know if it's going to be
macroscopic if you're going to be able
to bend a spoon with your mind
then it better stretch over at least a
few centimeters
more than that is allowed but less than
that becomes useless
you would never have detected the
graviton at particle accelerators you
still haven't
so how do you know there's not new
forces like that well turns out there
are also ways to detect
new forces and here what you're making
taking advantage of is
when you think about the force between
me and the apple pencil
i'm made of electrons protons and
neutrons i did make a tiny mistake i
made a big mistake in the video
because i said that beryllium was
element three where it's real really
lithium but i also made a tiny mistake
guessing that there were more neutrons
and protons in the human body
there's so much hydrogen and so much
oxygen and carbon and so forth in the
human body there are slightly more
protons
than than neutrons but what i need right
now is just the fact that
mostly i am made of protons neutrons and
electrons right that's true for a very
very good approximation likewise for the
pen
so if the rules of quantum field theory
are true the force that i can possibly
exert on another macroscopic object can
be thought of as
what is the force between the electrons
between electrons and protons electrons
and neutrons
protons and neutrons et cetera there's a
finite number of different things that
can happen
okay and then what you can do is take
objects of different compositions
and move them close to each other big
macroscopic hunking things you know like
kilometers
of mass bring them very very close you
know like centimeters millimeters even
tinier than that
and say what are the forces you can
certainly detect gravity that way
right the cavendish experiment does this
so you want to make the cavendish
experiment but much much
stronger and you want to you want to be
able to sort of look for forces
over and above the force of gravity so
there's a famous set of experiments
using torsion balances
and things like that and so for the
first i think for the first time
i'm not sure but for the first time i as
far as i can remember in the biggest
ideas videos i'm going to show you data
okay here we have actual
uh constraints from experiments on
new forces of nature and they basically
depend on two things
how strong is the force and what is the
range of the force
what you see is the vertical axis is how
strong the horizontal axis is
what is the range what you see is what
is ruled out
are forces in the upper right that is
when
either the range is strong is big or the
the strength of the of the force is
strong so the the
part of the graph where you're allowed
where there could be a force but we
haven't yet detected it
is either because the force is very weak
or because it's very short
range and if you look quantitatively at
the plot
for a new force of nature to have not
yet been discovered
if the strength of that force is
approximately equal to the strength of
gravity
then the range of that force has to be
less than a millimeter
okay now if you think of it that's
that's dead in the water right there in
terms of everyday physics because
to have two things be close enough to be
you know a millimeter across
uh so you need like millimeter sized
objects if they're bigger than that then
one end of the object is not exerting a
force more than a millimeter away right
so you need to get things within a
millimeter of each other
that are actually causing the force
but the gravitational force between two
objects of millimeter size
is almost completely negligible you know
it is completely negligible you know we
feel gravity in the world because
we're feeling the whole force of the
earth
but you don't feel the gravitational
force of your refrigerator when you're
in the kitchen it's just far far far
too weak so this is saying that any new
forces of nature
either have to be much much shorter
range than gravity
or much much much weaker than gravity
and either way
those two constraints say it's not going
to be relevant
to everyday physics so we have been
looking
for new forces that could be relevant we
have not found them we have ruled them
out
and there this is a slightly older plot
but there are even better constraints
now than there used to be
so the data are important the data are
in it's good to be able to show some
experimental results here in the biggest
ideas videos
um the laws of physics underlying our
everyday lives are completely known we
know what they are
there's plenty to be done plenty to be
done taking those laws of physics and
applying them to things quantum
computing would be one example of that
but then again so would chemistry
so with sociology or economics right you
know these are all
different ways that the laws of physics
play out and there's plenty more to be
done
nowhere near answering all the
interesting questions that we can think
of to ask